bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte
c'est la maladie animale la plus
dévastatrice dans le monde en ce moment
la peste porcine africaine fin octobre
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
animale annoncé que 25 % des ports de la
planète pourrait succomber à cette
maladie d'ici la fin de l'année
une véritable hécatombe qui fait frémir
l'industrie porcine incluant des
producteurs ici au canada même si le
pays est toujours exempt de la maladie
[Musique]
depuis un peu plus d'un an
la peste porcine africaine c'est la
manchette
cette maladie virale qui ne posent pas
de risque pour les humains tuent presque
tous les porcs infectés et elle se
propage à une vitesse fulgurante sur la
planète en termes d'impact sur les
productions animales c'est du jamais vu
un de toute ma carrière je n'ai jamais
vu quelque chose d'aussi sérieux
son nom le dit la maladie est originaire
d'afrique où elle est endémique dans une
vingtaine de pays
là bas les phacochères sont
naturellement résistants mais les
sangliers héliport domestiques n'ont pas
développé cette immunité
le virus se transmet via une piqûre de
tique ou par contact avec des cochons
infectés et ce virus est très persistant
il survit même à la congélation de la
viande les ouvriers agricoles la
machinerie mais aussi les voyageurs qui
importe de la nourriture peuvent être
des vecteurs
malgré des foyers d'éclosion ponctuelle
à l'extérieur de l'afrique à partir des
années 1950 la peste porcine africaine
demeurait relativement contrôlée dans le
monde
mais depuis un signalement en géorgie en
2007 on n'arrive plus à freiner sa
propagation vers l'ouest comme vers
l'est et c'est son arrivée dans un pays
qui a fait complètement basculer les
statistiques la chine en ou 2018 le pays
rapporte son premier cas de peste
porcine africaine
au début on n'a pas réalisé l'ampleur
cette maladie spécialiste du commerce
international le professeur jones ou
suit de près l'évolution de la peste
porcine africaine vrai que c'est très
rapidement cattier totalité des
provinces chinoises ont été touchés avec
plus de 400 millions de porcs
la chine est le premier producteur au
monde et c'est aussi le pays qui en
consomment le plus
la chine comptera vaut près de 19% la
population mondiale
si c'est 19% coordination qui conte
semble quasiment 50% de porc aux
mondiaux ça veut dire qu'en fait que
c'est un des produits alimentaires
majeures dans les assiettes de beaucoup
pour beaucoup de chinois
depuis un an le prix de cette viande a
doublé en chine car le port se fait de
plus en plus rares dans le pays
c'est un processus très douloureux pour
un éleveur de porcs c'est pénible sound
house est à la tête d'un grand
conglomérat qui compte plusieurs fermes
porcines
il a perdu 15 mille bêtes cette année en
ce moment les fermiers sont craintes et
feel juice pas élevé porte
il n'existe pas encore de vaccin contre
la peste porcine africaine et les
éleveurs qui essaient de redémare y
échoue donc tout le monde à part
en chine la moitié du port est encore
produit dans de modestes ferme familiale
c'est les grands éleveurs ne sont pas
épargnés les petits ils sont des
dizaines de millions sont les plus
durement touchés peu d'animaux par ferme
fait que les mesures de biosécurité dans
ce genre d'élevage c'est presque asie -
impossible à mettre en place
vétérinaire de formation niels bohr mon
analyse les marchés mondiaux de la
viande depuis trois décennies
on peut exiger d'un éleveur qu'ils
prennent une douche avant de rentrer
qu'ils se changent complètement avant
d'entrer dans un élevage important celui
qui va voir trois ports le matin le midi
et le soir ne va pas prendre sa douche
trois fois par jour etc
c'est absolument impossible
une pénurie de vétérinaires et le manque
de transparence n'ont pas aidé à contrer
la maladie
les foyers d'infestation ont d'abord été
rapportées au compte gouttes ce qui
donne l impression que la situation
était maîtrisée
encore aujourd'hui le pays n'a déclaré
qu 1,2 million de bêtes abattues alors
que les analystes indépendants par le
plus tôt de 150 à 200 millions de porcs
touchés john fia a vu son troupeau de
600 cochon mourir les autorités locales
nous ont dit de nous taire on nous a
menacé en disant qu'il y aurait des
conséquences si on déclarait des cas le
principe adopté par le coi devant
chinois c'est toujours essayé de
rassurer les gens en d'autres termes
c'est si à des mauvaises nouvelles
il vaut mieux ne pas rendre au public la
crainte de perte financière a aussi joué
dans la balance
certains éleveurs n'ose pas signalé leur
bête malade mais il continue à les
vendre en douce le prix peut être de
quelques sous de moins par bell alors
c'est avantageux pour eux de les
éliminer de cette façon
le virus qui provoque une hémorragie
interne chez l'animal s'est donc
propagée comme une traînée de poudre
laissant place à des scènes désolantes
comme ici dans le sud du pays
[Musique]
c'est une situation malheureuse mais
c'est la réalité
vous savez dans le cas de petits
éleveurs ils n'ont pas beaucoup de
moyens et aussi ils sont un peu mous
mois conscientiser sur la gravité de la
situation
si on redouble d'efforts actuellement
pour développer un vaccin
il faudra des années avant qu'il ne soit
disponible en attendant la seule méthode
pour freiner l'avancée du virus et
l'élimination massive dé beir et leur
enfouissement profond des images
troublantes souvent censuré par les
autorités qui démontre l'ampleur de la
crise en chine
évidemment ça fait très mal pour nous de
voir ces animaux qui étaient
enterré vivant parfois brûlés vivants et
c'est l'élimination sanitaire des
animaux en cas d'épidémie de ce genre
pose toujours énormément de problèmes
c'est très très compliquée à mettre en
oeuvre correctement et la chine n'est
pas seul face à ce fléau comme un triste
jeu de dominos de nombreux pays d'asie
aussi dépendant des petits élevages ont
été infectées les uns après les autres
on n'avait pas imaginé que ça irait
aussi vite parce que on n'a pas les
mêmes structures d'élevage chez nous et
on apprend toujours avec l'expérience
la menace est aujourd'hui globale et
tous les pays sont à risque d'être
contaminé c'est ça arrivait ce serait
une catastrophe pour les david duval
élèves plus de 30000 port par année il
crée la peste porcine puisque tous enfin
producteurs c'est dans mes premières
priorités a essayé d'éviter qu'à une
contamination
ici au canada les autorités sont sur un
pied d'alerté 31 millions de dollars ont
été investis cette année pour former de
nouveaux chiens renifleurs capable de
détecter des produits du porc
la surveillance aux frontières est
cruciale on pense pas que les fermes
québécoises ou canadiennes vont être
affectés dans la ferme pourquoi parce
qu'on met tout des règles de biosécurité
assez stressé ou ce que ça pourrait
rendre et qu'on pense que ça pourrait
rentrer ce soit par des singuliers ou
soit par mettons quelqu'un qui a amené
des produits des produits de viande de
porc et qui aurait malencontreusement
jeté son c'est nous et chez les cochons
quand ça serait dramatique pour toute
l'industrie
autant la production la transformation
ça serait vraiment majeur
sylvain fournaise et vétérinaire en chef
chez olymel le principal exportateur de
porc canadien à partir du moment où un
corps seraient déclarés un seul corps sa
mère nous fermeture des frontières
canadiennes à l'exportation comme on
exporte déjà 70% de notre volume de
viande dont klaus aura un impact majeur
en 2017 les exportations canadiennes de
porc était évaluée à quatre milliards de
dollars
la viande qu'on ne peut pas vain les
canadiens vont consommer sans dispose en
plus de parts donc il va falloir prendre
des actions sociales là également les
espaces d'entreposage comme ici on voit
on est déjà plein au jour le jour aussi
demain matin le produit sans porc on a
un problème
[Musique]
mais ce n'est pas le scénario qui se
joue en ce moment
la chine a levé le mois dernier les
sanctions contre le porc canadien et le
marché chinois a besoin d'un volume
colossal de viande porcine et les
observateurs mettent en garde ceux qui
voudraient investir dans le marché
chinois à long terme
en 15 ans la chine a construit le plus
grand réseau de tgv au monde et elle
entend bâtir une industrie porcine de
premier plan plus rapidement encore dans
la populaire chinois le mot crise est
composé de deux mots premiers mots 70g
une situation de crise c'est beaucoup de
tanger c'est ce que la chine est en
train de vivre sur marché de port n'est
ce pas mais l'autre mot ces opportunités
c'est très philosophique n'est ce pas je
pense que la chine n'a pas d'autre choix
pas d'autre choix que de restructurer et
de moderniser sa production porcine
voici des gratte-ciel à cochons mille
port par étage avec des ascenseurs pour
faciliter les déplacements dans un pays
où l'espace est limité ce sont peut-être
les porcheries du futur surtout que les
visées du gouvernement chinois sont
claires pékin souhaite favoriser les
grands éleveurs ou détriment des petits
et surtout le gouvernement veut que la
chine demeure le plus possible autour
suffisante en port
les grands producteurs étrangers peuvent
voir des opportunités intéressantes
ok mais à long terme je dirais qu'il ya
toujours des opportunités mais il faut
pas penser que la chine devient
dépendant de son produit envers tous les
autres pays je prends pas cela
[Musique]
on le voyait dans le reportage la peste
porcine africaine ne pose pas de risque
pour la santé humaine
on ne peut pas attraper le virus même en
mangeant de la viande contaminée par
contre l'épidémie menace
l'approvisionnement mondial
d'anticoagulants ces produits là sont
fabriqués à partir de l'héparine une
substance qui est extraite des muqueuses
intestinales des ports jusqu'ici la
chine fournissait près des deux tiers de
l'approvisionnement mondial d'héparine